[Music]
hello and welcome to a very special
edition of the week in 60 minutes it's
in fact the year in 60 minutes because
it's our special Christmas edition we
have gone to press with our Christmas
edition of the print magazine which is
here and how very beautiful it is every
year um it's an absolutely wonderful
Edition and this year is no exception I
strongly recommend if you don't
subscribe to this magazine that you do
so immediately uh and you can do that by
going to ww. spectator.
co.uk
subscribe uh and um you should
definitely just buy this on the newst if
you see it too uh the week in 60 minutes
that's what this episode is uh my name
is Freddy gray uh I'm the deputy editor
of the magazine uh and I will be your
host
today well what a year it's been and uh
we are going to be talking about that
with two Heavy Hitters from The
Spectator Andrew Neil our chairman uh
and the great columnist Rod little next
up we'll be talking about whether third
parties or new parties are going to
start making a difference in British
politics in the coming months I'll be
joined by a leader of a third party the
third party at the moment according to
the polls um in British politics that's
Richard TI leader of the Reform Party
and the female activist Kelly J Keen AKA
posie Parker next up we will look abroad
and talk to the international relations
expert and Scholar John
mimer uh about the war in Ukraine and
about the situation in Gaza and the
Middle
East and finally we will turn towards
God because Christmas is about God after
all uh I'll be talking to Ed West uh
about a very interesting piece he has on
the new theists uh in the Christmas
edition of The Spectator magazine uh and
I'll be talking to him and Mary
Harrington uh about whether Christianity
is making a comeback before we get going
not only should you subscribe to The
Spectator magazine look at this
wonderful Christmas issue again uh you
should subscribe to our YouTube channel
if you do not already click the
Subscribe button to join 325,000 others
who have made that sensible
decision now who better to discuss uh
the year in politics in
2023 than the spectators chairman Andrew
Neil who joins us now along with uh The
Spectators columnist the great Rod
little um hello to you both thank youo
happy Christmas FR Merry Christmas Happy
Christmas to you both uh Andrew I'll
start with you um let's start with the
recent and at home um rishy sunx uh
ruanda bill passed last night in the
House of Commons um but it's a bit of a
sorry State for the Tory party is it not
uh when this was seen as a victory for
sunk um and actually it was just the
avoiding of a of a huge defeat was it
not I think I I'll file sorry State
under a British understatement I think
uh yes he does live to fight another day
by winning the vote you know shock
horror government with majority of 80
wins vote um but it doesn't change very
much I mean the the dominant feature of
British politics in
2023 has been the failure of the
conservatives in general and Mr sunak in
particular to move the dial uh that
labor leader of around 20 points just
stays solid it doesn't matter what the
Tes do uh they try a relaunch in the
summer they try a new pitch at their
conference they have an Autumn statement
uh they try to um put more life into the
illegal boats into the boat people
policy none of it moves the dial it is
almost the exact opposite of what
happened when John Major took over from
Margaret Thatcher uh in 1990 when John
Major took over of because there hadn't
been musical chairs of leadership she'd
been there for 11 years she was by then
unpopular but John Major for a while saw
an uplift in the polls for the Tories it
moved the dial this time it hasn't and I
think that Mr sudak is haunted by the
fact that he's not a new leader that's
taken over from a long standing leader
he's a new leader that's taken over from
David Cameron Theresa May Boris Johnson
Liz truss H and with all that game of
musical chair it would seem to me that
the Tory credibility is shot to hell and
things won't be any different next year
either and Andrew I mean the beginning
of the year I remember Tories talking
quite a lot about sunak still having a
narrow path to victory at the next
general election do you think that path
is now non-existent it's close to
non-existent I mean I'm always reluctant
to uh Say Never because we do live in a
very fee political age uh and things can
change very quickly uh I mean i' look at
America far from Donald Trump being
under pressure now in Iowa his lead is
in inreasing in Iowa and he'll romp home
in the Iowa caucuses on January the 15th
so we we we live in in in a time when
suddenly it can all just go hell to
Skelter but sitting here with the
knowledge we have now again the news as
we uh uh record this of the British
economy actually uh
declining uh in October there's no sense
of economic momentum there's no sign of
living standards return turning to
growth inflation for some Curious reason
is more stubbornly High here than it is
in any other major economy so again I
don't see what happens that moves the
dial and if I was to really come down to
one thing I would say it's it is in the
end this other than this absurd game of
musical chairs that the Tories have been
treating the country to I regard Richi
sunik as a decent man a decent man uh a
competent man uh a bit technocratic but
nevertheless a patriot has the best
interest of the country at hard works
very very hard but for some reason he
just doesn't have that X Factor that
leadership quality that allows you to
build a return and instead it's really
what Jim kakin said in 1979 when he was
beaten by uh margar Thatcher he was told
in the runup to the election hey Jim
there is still a Pathway to Victory for
you and he basically said no there comes
a time when it's over uh the country's
made up its mind and the other lot
should be given a chance and for good or
ill I think that's exactly where we are
now well Rod I suppose thank God for
Britain and the British left that they
have the hugely charismatic kir starma
uh leading the labor party to a general
election Victory next year yeah I mean I
Andrew summed it up beautifully I think
uh I mean it is very similar to what we
were saying this time last year nothing
has changed very much I mean and what
was implied in what what what Andrew was
saying was uh nobody voted for rishy
sunak you know U the British people
didn't vote for Richie sunak the British
people didn't vote for for Liz truss the
British people didn't vote for Theresa
May uh and there is so there's this IM
immense weariness with the conservative
party
um which will not go away and there is
nothing you can do to move the dial on
that um there was one suspicion that
perhaps if inflation came down and wages
began to rise a little bit which is
always a a difficult Paradox to pull off
uh that that perhaps the position would
be better for the conservative party but
there is also the feeling amongst those
who particularly up here that there's
been a sort of Palace coup uh while
there's no great
love left for Boris Johnson uh the
people up here who voted overwhelmingly
for for the conservative party in 2019
now see that the conservative part is
back on its usual uh liberal remainer
trajectory and have want to have nothing
to do with it it's very odd because it
seems that nobody nobody actually at all
in any of the parties AP from mine
obviously uh wants to have anything to
do with the red wall voters you know
because sakir stama doesn't uh doesn't
appeal to them very much either um so so
so there's all of that as for the left
there there's a slight hope there's a
slight hope that for the Tories that
something ghastly will happen to the
labor party as a consequence of the
Israel Gaza crisis where we have seen
starma under serious pressure uh and
there are a number of seats in the
country which are extremely problematic
for the labor party if it wishes to win
uh um
an overall majority which are either
Muslim majority a couple of them I think
it's Bradford East or it might be
Bradford West and Birmingham Hall green
uh and there's another 30 or 40 where
the Muslim vote is decisive and whilst
62% of Muslims at the last election
voted on mass for the labor party that
was the last figure I saw was down to 8%
I mean that is enormous and you can
imagine the chaos for labor if uh genial
George Galloway decides to take up the
battle uh with respect and fight in
these seats and put candidates up for
respect in the various other seats where
the Muslims are are a large proportion
of the vote and we'll see a bit of that
uh I think in the London meril election
where I think Galloway May stand himself
so it's all it's all it's all very
interesting I the only Pro the problem
there electorally is that actually as
newspaper Proprietors and editors
well know the Israel Gaza crisis balls
the British public into submission much
as did Russia and Ukraine that's why U
it's dropped down from the headlines a
little bit uh because actually it
doesn't have a great resonance with with
the voter with the reader uh or the
viewer uh that this isn't a story which
particularly grabs hold of them what
grabs hold of them is immigration uh it
is the the cost of living and it is
inflation um but it it's but Foreign
Affairs never tends to impinge that much
I mean I think the the the other big
political theme it's almost the mirror
image of the theme of the Tories being
unable to move the dial is that it it's
clear the countries are in love with the
Tories there's no question about that
it's over as far as the country is
concerned but it's not gagging for k
starmer um you know they're not
desperate say oh if only K starmer was
in turn down Street they don't feel that
way at all the way they did for Tony
Blair in 96 leading up to 987 which is
why I still have some doubts that
there'll be a huge labor majority I mean
there'll be a comfortable labor majority
and big enough for five years if that if
they want to go for five but it won't be
a blairite type uh Landslide on the
other hand they're not frightened of
karma the way they were a bit frightened
of Neil kinck in uh ' 87 and '92 they
were frightened a little bit or
or or just didn't rate Ed millerand uh
in 2015 they were definitely frightened
particularly up in the red wall on of
Jeremy Corbin they're not frightened of
karma like that they see him as a
relative safe pair ofans Rod mentioned
the cost of living which of course
domestically has been by far the most
important political issue and the news I
just come back from the states the news
from America there is dire for the
Tories and the reason I say that is this
that the American economy is in far
better shape than the British economy
unemployment is at record lows growth in
the third quarter was an annual rate of
4% living standards are rising again
interest rates are coming down inflation
is down to about 3% it's a pretty Rosy
economic scenario and the Biden
Administration is getting no credit
whatsoever and the reason for that is
the cost of living because although
inflation is down price are still a lot
higher than they were and they've risen
by a lot more than wages so people still
feel bitter about the cost of living now
put that into a British context where
the economy is essentially stagnating
unlike America and the cost of living
crisis is still working its way through
and I think you look at 2024 and if
what's playing out in America and
harming the Biden Administration is
going to play out in Britain and harm
the sunich administration which is a
much worse economic tale to tell
anyway I I think that's right it's it's
quite interesting I was looking at the
at the figures I in a in a way this
reminds me and Andrew alluded to this
that there isn't the same degree of of
fervor for for I'm just trying to
imagine anyone being fervent for saki St
around it just doesn't really work does
it there's not the same furor for secur
stor that there was for Tony Blair
in a way it reminds me a little bit of
the of the 1964 general election where
you had a conservative party that had
been in power for uh 13 years uh I
suppose 13 years um with a multiplicity
of leaders Churchill Eden McMillan
Douglas Hume um and a public which was
sick of them uh and and I was reading
David kon's book uh about U 62 to 64 in
Great Britain U which was the time when
we built all these horrible shopping
centers and so on and the thing which
which bleeds through from that is how
within the conservative party they
simply couldn't um they couldn't shift
the dial at all that that the public had
registered a weariness and that
weariness wasn't going to go away and at
the time they weren't expecting Harold
Wilson particularly to be uh uh to be
the next prime minister it didn't really
matter it was whoever labor had who
wasn't actually you know mentally
impaired so it all reminds me a little
bit of that but if if as seems almost
inevitable as discussed that we are Le
we are heading towards Britain having a
center left I think we can call Labor a
center left party now A Center left
government Britain would then be bucking
the trend that we've seen in 2023 would
it not Andrew of um you mentioned Trump
earlier who seems to be um now uh the
favorite the bookie's favorite to win
the presidential election next year
we'll see about that um but you know we
have Javier m in Argentina we have ger
Wilders in Holland we have the European
elections coming up next year in June
where where the right are supposed to to
sweep the board um the drift of global
politics is going right quite sharply is
it
not yes it is and to that extent Britain
is out of kilter I think actually K
starma realizes that which is why he's
moved labor much more to the center than
I ever thought he would I mean I mean I
you know when I interviewed him for the
leadership race way back in the just
before the pandemic in early 2020 I mean
he campaigned and won the leadership on
a Carbonite
Manifesto uh he had 10 pledges all of
which came from the labor Manifesto of
2019 we knew he would resile from that
over time but I never thought he would
go so far and then suddenly we have a
labor conference in which the Union flag
is flown proudly they sing the national
anthem God Save the King uh the you know
we going to be fiscally conservative uh
but we will protect defense spending we
uh the defense of the realm allies with
the United States all of that is now
part of the labor Mantra and I think
that is a kind of recognition that
although the country we are out of the
global political cycle and the to people
are fed up with the Tories he knows as I
say they're not gagging for him or for
labor and that he cannot afford to be
very far from the center left I mean
Rod's been writing with this and we tell
his more but there you know we keep on
thinking and it's wishful thinking for a
number of the media that the populous
Revolt is coming to an end uh and and
every time we it's it's like you know
every three years The Economist magazine
identifies an African success
story and within three weeks of that
article being published there's been a
coup and people are being slaughtered in
the street and is e it's back to poverty
and penury and I and you know the force
is look The Spectator had a very good
article I don't necessarily disagree
with her at all Leen could be the next
president of France you know as things
stand at the moment she'd probably have
to be a favorite the second biggest
party in Germany is now the afd uh Italy
has a populist prime minister the Sweden
Democrats not the social Democrats the
Sweden Democrats are now praying playing
a role in Sweden's government uh so you
see all of that beginning to happen and
that is before another recession comes
in and of course we have the Resurgence
of Donald Trump no matter how many
lawsuits are thrown at him he just seems
to go from strength to strength The Wall
Street Journal poll which ends the year
chose now four five points ahead of Mr
Biden uh and in five out of the six
swing States Wisconsin being the odd man
out he's ahead in five out of the six
states that will determine the election
populism has not gone away and I think
Rod is better qualified to explain that
than I
am Andrew is absolutely right I mean it
it hasn't really not gone away it's
simply coming to fruition and has been
doing so for a period of around about 12
to 13 years U perhaps even longer when
you remember pin fortain in in the
Netherlands back in the early 2000s and
vams block people like that i' I'd take
a you as to whether it's simply a
right-wing movement uh when you look at
uh for example one of the most recent
victories which was that of Robert uh I
can't remember how you pronounce it so
name FICO is how you pronounce it if he
was Italian but he isn't he Slovakian
um
perhaps uh that's a Social Democratic
party and it's
redistributive uh and but it's also very
very hard line on immigration on Islam
on uh and on the various cultural
identitarian issues such as like the
Danny Center left too no exactly and and
there are plenty of these parties around
when when you look at Europe and you're
saying it's the end of populism and kid
Builders stps the poll in the
Netherlands and the Swiss decid side
that they've had enough as well this is
a it's a revolt against neoliberalism
and that's very difficult for K Dharma
to deal with it's also obviously
difficult for Richi sun to deal with
because they're both birds of the same
feather when it comes to that particular
particular ideology uh and which is why
there is some Hunger for for people like
farage who despite being basically a
thatcherite economically uh which is
certainly what he would claim to be um
uh there he still takes a tough line on
the social issues which are which are
the things which are annoying an awful
lot of people in Europe uh I mean he is
a thatcherite isn't he I mean I don't
think there's much getting away from
that the other thing I mean which is
quite interesting is when you look at
the opinion polls for the 2019 election
up here in the red wall seats there was
no great aversion uh up here to the
economic policies which John McDonald
was suggesting uh would be in the labor
Manifesto
uh which was basically leftwing populism
um and and taxing the rich and and so on
inheritance tax etc etc etc uh the
objection was always to their lack of
patriotism and to the idiotic Foreigner
foreign alignments that that Jeremy
Corbin had whether it be with herass
Venezuela Cuba Etc so it's it's an
anti-neoliberal thing yes I think and I
I think that is is what it what is
driving it and it may be even New
Zealand you know that strange hermit
Kingdom of New Zealand um and it may
well be that this often happens we are
out of step with the rest of Europe
partly because of our first Passos
system which is looking increasingly
anachronistic uh but when it comes to
the next election I suspect it will
still be a neoliberal government which
wins I I I think Rod's right the a lot
of the media commentry which is based on
populism equals rightwing uh particular
hard right view of the world motivated
Above All by anti-immigration that's a
very unsophisticated analysis um the
fact is it alludes to what Rod was
saying if you look at the economic
policies of Madame Leen and France and
the economic policies of melong Mr M
Shong the sort of Jeremy Corbin of
France there's not that much difference
they both want a big state they both
want uh State control of Industry they
both want uh a massive increase in the
minimum wage they're both protectionists
they're both anti- Euro they are very
much against neoliberal economics and so
on so the there is a left and a
right-wing populism comes together here
and and that needs to be appreciated
more because otherwise it's just too
easy to dismiss or it's just a bunch of
right-wing Nutters uh it's much deeper
than
that amazing to think isn't it that
Nicholas Duron uh was still first
minister of Scotland beginning of this
year it feels as I said uh we're in fee
out times all predictions can quickly be
unfounded now as we've just been
discussing uh people are pretty Fed Up
of the conservative party that much is
clear in the polls and it's also clear
um from extensive polling that not
everybody's very excited about Labor and
the thought of an incoming labor
government which should you'd think uh
pay the way for uh other parties a third
party to emerge I'm going to discuss
this now with Richard TI who is the uh
leader of Reform the Reform Party and
Kelly Jade Keane who is founder of
standing for women uh and is attempting
to form a new or has been attempting to
reform form a new political party called
the party of women is that right Kelly
Jane the party of women it is yes that's
house um uh Richard I'll start with you
you are now the third party uh in
British politics uh according to the
latest polling you're on 11% above uh
the liberal Democrats on about 10%
though I accept these things are
variable um that's taken uh it's taken
you a while to get some of the political
momentum you probably expected a bit
sooner uh do you anticipate now surging
ahead into
2024 yeah look building any brand in any
Walk of Life takes time and a lot of
hard work in particular in the political
world where you've got a basically a
two-party system first pass the post
that that solidifies and reinforces that
system but actually we're making great
progress no one else ever has achieved
what reform UK has achieved in two years
going from essentially somewhere around
1% up to 10 11% I bet by early 24 will
be 12% plus and that's basically because
people feel politically homeless in the
two main parties they both represent a
different differing forms of socialism
High tax High regulation Mass
immigration pret zero Nanny State
meaning low growth and people are saying
that's not very attractive what else is
out there and word is spreading in the
pubs and clubs and the bus stops and I'm
delighted we're making great great
progress and look Rome's not built in a
day but we're heading north and success
breeds success so I think people should
not underestimate Us in the election
year of 2024 you changed your uh name
from the brexit party to Reform Party um
you hinted in a recent article that you
thought perhaps that had been a mistake
do you do you still think that would you
like to clarify
that look fundamentally the country
needs massive reform everywhere that's
why we changed it the brexit party is a
very well-known brand so a brand
specialist would say well why did you
change we changed because we trusted the
conservatives uh when they said get
brexit done we thought they actually
meant it and uh but actually given that
there's so many problems across the
whole piece we don't regret it it just
means it takes a bit longer for people
to recognize who you are where you've
come from what we've done on our logo is
we've actually added in the words the
brexit party so we're called reform UK
but the logo also includes the brexit
party that provides a bit of extra
Clarity and linkage for people but no
we're very proud of of our brand and
what we're achieving and Kelly Jane your
party was initially uh rejected I think
I'm right in saying by the Electoral uh
commission um it seemed to me on a point
of procedure yeah uh can you can you
clarify what's going on
there well look I don't want to uh cast
aspersions at the um Commission Office
the Electoral Commission office but they
have been rejecting us since March so
I've now instructed a barrister to make
sure that every single T and and uh I is
is perfectly dotted because I I just
don't want to give them any uh any
reason to dismiss us again uh so no
stone left unturned so that's why we've
we've got a barister and I'm very
confident in the in our electoral
process and our democracy that that
we'll be registered really soon
and your intention for for you yourself
is to stand either against Eddie isard
uh in Sheffield or against kir starma
himself is that right yeah well I think
Eddie's now going for Brighton so it was
going to be K starma but I look it it
will depend as we near the election
where I will stand I think you know
there's there's a lot of lovely MPS
right across the board that I would
stand against Stella crey uh would be
one of them I think there's so many so
in all political parties uh who've just
turned their backs on women as well as
huge sways of the population you know
most people know that women don't have
penises and and it's about time that
parties said it and the the conservative
party are a little bit too late with
their their sort of strength on this
topic and they're still really not far
enough for me you know there's still
this stuff has has got ravaged through
schools you know the I I visited a
school recently it's this stuff is
everywhere so there is a there is a
calling for a party that represents
women and that would be mine and by this
stuff you mean uh the trans
agenda I don't just think it's that but
is that look that is the most egregious
lie and upon which the foundation uh
upon which so many other lies rest so
the gr would be something the gender
recognition act would be something I
would like to see completely repealed um
I want all of this stuff out of schools
as of yesterday not just trans stuff but
other lies that we consistently tell
children um but I I just think this is
the most egregious when you're talking
about the fundamentals upon which all of
us are here you know a woman gives birth
to babies and a man is the the person
that impregnates that woman and I think
it's um it's Bonkers but yeah there
there too many lies but but that's
that's the biggest uh Richard Kelly's
attempts uh to speak up for women there
are often brand the sort of culture
Waring and so on uh do you think the
Reform Party is in a good position on
the culture walls or do you think uh the
Tory party which is sort of dabbling a
little bit in culture wars uh has stolen
a bit of your old Thunder
there uh far from it actually the Troy
party have given up on standing up for
uh British culture British values
they're all over the place on this and
it's only reform actually that have been
really strong amongst the top three or
four polling parties is we've made it
absolutely crystal clear there should be
none of this uh gender questioning
allowing any social transitioning any
debate about this in schools up to the
age of 18 we think it's it's absurd I'm
going to campaign events up and down the
country parents and grandparents are
utterly fuming and Furious at what is
going along uh the uh the sort of the
hiding of information the third party
providers some of whom providing
material that is nothing short frankly
of revolting we've been Crystal Clear we
ban the whole lot and it's the sort of
thing that actually you could do within
just a few days let me tell you what I'd
do Freddy if I was prime minister I'd
instruct the Secretary of State for
education to write to ofstead to write
to every single head teacher of every
primary and secondary school saying this
stops by Friday and anybody who carries
on is fired no ifs no buts it's a breach
of contract here's the most important
thing though it's the the clearest most
dangerous breach of safeguarding I've
ever seen and I've been a governor of
four different schools you see all these
safeguarding documents hundreds and
hundreds of pages long this is the most
obvious clear breach and it should stop
and for the prime minister to say back
in March he was going to car out an
urgent review my definition of urgent is
by the end of the day or the end of the
week we're in December and there's no
sign of this review they're all over the
place and they're letting children down
it's a disgrace Kelly J I know you got
your own uh political Ambitions but are
you persuaded by Richard's uh pitch
there I am I think it's it's a barometer
of where we are as a society that that
the smaller of the major three parties
is having to say this because the two
main parties have failed dismally to say
it but yes look anybody speaking about
the truth about this about uh whether or
not human beings can actually change sex
I welcome all of that discourse I think
it's really really needed
one thing that we want to do as a party
of women is we want to build from the
bottom up so whilst I have Ambitions to
become an MP or I I really have
Ambitions to to make a big noise so that
other people can understand what the
issues are and force people into
positions that's that's my ambition um
but I want I want grind up so I want
women in seats uh right across the
country and councils because that's
where really direct politics happens
whether or not um an elderly woman in
her home when she says she'd like a
female carer to come and intimately care
for her I want that woman to know that a
female will actually turn up not not a a
cheap worker um who's a man or a a man
in address I I just I just think those
things are really crucial so I'd like us
just to populate the local councils and
the pcc's and all of those where direct
uh democracy and politics really
happen do you think uh people will call
you a single issue party a single-issue
politician uh do you think you are I
mean are you the the women don't have
penises
candidate well I am that um but I'm I
think look women don't live single-issue
lives um and I think it's really
important for both men and women to be
able to walk about their lives and
expect their public services and
institutions to recognize them as men
and women and that Coster caring um and
adoption uh services and all of those
other services are not co-opted by what
I think is a quasi religious pernicious
Cult of transgenderism and just and and
lies and and like I said there's other
lies that stem from that so whilst it
may be single issue I mean the brexit
party may have been accused of being
single issue and I believe we are now no
longer in Europe so I think the power of
single issue is is perhaps something
that we need need in in this country at
the moment so that people can really
kind of stake stake their claim to a
particular principal and that's
something that I think we stand for at
the party of women or we will stand for
once we're registered is a principal Le
um party which is not it's not like come
and just put all of your eggs in our
basket but it's if you care about this
particular issue this is what we're
talking
about and uh Richard I suppose uh the
question I wanted to ask actually both
of you is on this particular issue of uh
transgender the transgender agenda um
against women's rights um the Tory party
have sort of dabbled with it as you say
perhaps ineffectively Richard um but do
we as in the media do we underestimate
quite how the strength of feeling um
that this has generated actually POS you
answer this first the strength of
feeling that this is generated uh among
women that this issue is now generating
and the the extent to which women feel
um that their rights are now being
infringed by a hostile agenda
yeah yeah well I I see my job is as not
to convince people because everything
everybody I think already agrees with me
it's just about ensuring that women
understand and Men I don't want to just
I'm not just I'm I I am speaking mainly
to women but I think it impacts all of
us that actually there is a space for
those views that it's not it's no longer
um you know a Sil majority we have to
people have to speak up and just being a
little bit apathetic and thinking it's
happening somewhere else is not good
enough anymore because for a start it is
happening it's happening everywhere I
spoke to two teachers a couple of weeks
ago who bareface lied to parents um just
it was it's one of the most horrific uh
sort of conversations I've ever had to
have where you just understand that
these people are pretty much paid up
members of a cult and they are willing
to take the place of parents and make
decisions about people's children behind
their back um and sort of treat parents
with absolute contempt so I think once
people understand that it's in their
children's schools I wouldn't like to be
uh I wouldn't like to predict how they
vote in the next election but it it
can't be for either the conservatives or
labor if they really care about this
issue and Richard have you have you
noticed that I mean because your main
issue I think as a party is immigration
now certainly you know post brexit uh
you are becoming the party that talks
about what what you and and verage
call uh the population crisis in Britain
um but how much does that go hand inand
with this more cultur war um stuff that
is is bubbling under the surface in
British politics bubbling under the
surface insh there are multiple
challenges across frankly the whole
nation and many of them interrelate uh
but this is this this issue the trans
agenda it is it has arisen so quickly it
surprised so many decent ordinary folk
and parents up and down the country and
when I speak to groups they just can't
believe it it it flies in the face
frankly of all basic common sense and I
think too often actually politicians fly
in the face of basic Common Sense look
we're pretty strong and robust on a
number of these issues we are
comfortable talking about the
uncomfortable for many people we feel
that in a sense we've got the courage to
put a head above the parapets and take
the Flack because so many parents they
get in real trouble if they try and
raise this as I'm sure Kelly has seen
with with teachers or headteachers
they're worried that in some way their
their child might be discriminated
against as far as I'm concerned uh it's
absolutely simple there are two Sexes
and two genders male and female you
might feel something else at some point
cuz you've had a bad day or a good day
fine but I'm just not buying all this 72
gender 100 gender stuff you you talk to
ordinary folk up and down the country
they look at you with amazement they
think it's nonsense they think it's
absurd and they just want actually
politicians to get on to make people's
lives better and they're just furious
that so much time and and sort of
cowardice is is wasted on trying to say
that
frankly something just basically isn't
biologically true
uh and sort of pretend that it is and
pretend that women can have penises I
mean it's it's the most absurd statement
in the
world uh I'm not going to try and do
what a lot of journalists have done with
you Richard which is try and insinuate
there's some sort of rivalry between you
and Nigel forage because you always
reject that idea but um he has just left
the the celebrity jungle um in third
place he's his public profile has
increased he's made a lot of hints about
coming into politics he's made hints
about wanting to lead the conservative
party um perhaps after it implodes at
the next general election um where do
you stand on if Niger frage wants to go
back to the Reform Party is he the
leader do you do you step aside what
what happens look he's had great fun
playing mischief and causing Division
and divide within the conservative party
but I remind everybody he's our honorary
president he set up the Reform Party
when it was called the brexit party he
has come back from the jungle on great
form a little bit lighter love the
experience his pole ratings gone through
the roof he's utterly furious at what's
transpired with regard to some of the
key issues that affect uh our quality of
life and I I I I've said very clearly to
everybody the more help that we can get
the better the more that Nigel is able
to help get stuck in put his shoulder
behind the wheel and frankly uh help
save Britain from the state that we're
in then the better and and I suspect
you'll be hearing a lot more on this
matter in the coming
weeks Richard and Kelly Jane uh wish you
both uh a politically prosperous 2024
because um given the morban state of
British politics anything new is good uh
I think in our opinion at The
Spectator now let's turn to Foreign
Affairs and I'm delighted to be joined
Again by John mimer who is a professor
of international relations uh and he is
based at the University of
Chicago and he's also been I think it's
fair to say John you've been quite
controversial this year uh I know you
might disagree with that label but
you've been quite controversial this
year and last um in your uh arguments on
Ukraine Russia um and now as we will
talk about in a bit on uh
Gaza um but let's start with the news uh
if we may about Ukraine because zilinsky
was in Washington uh last night tonight
um pleading for u a $60 billion Aid
package which it looks as though is not
going to be forthcoming um but President
Joe Biden has reiterated his support for
Ukraine um are we at a stage now where
American support for the Ukraine is
starting to EB not just among some
Republicans as people always like to say
but among Democrats and the political
class I think there's no question about
that I I think that uh uh up until uh
the late summer uh most uh of the
foreign policy establishment most people
in the foreign policy establishment in
the United States thought there was a
good chance that uh Ukraine could win
the war actually defeat the Russians
inside of Ukraine I think it's now clear
that that's not the case I think it's
clear to almost everybody that the
balance of power has shifted in a marked
way in the Russians favor and
independent of this Aid package uh the
Russians are on the March and there's
all sorts of reasons to think that the
ukrainians are going to have a very
difficult time stemming the tide uh so I
think this overall pessimism independent
of the aid package uh has contributed to
the pessimism here in the United States
and the unwillingness of people to Fork
out huge amounts of money to Ukraine
would you then argue uh that uh
essentially the Western push to help
Ukraine has been futile I think there's
no question I've argued for a long time
that we are leading Ukraine down the
Primrose path uh I think that pushing to
bring Ukraine into NATO was a huge
mistake and uh Putin made it clear when
we announced in April 2008 that we were
going to pursue that policy that he
would destroy Ukraine before he would
let that happen and in fact that is what
happened is happening uh Ukraine is
already lost a substantial portion of
its territory and I believe will lose
more and it will end up as a
dysfunctional rum State uh so this is a
disaster for Ukraine I believe if we
hadn't pushed forward to bring Ukraine
into NATO that Ukraine would probably be
intact today there would be no war uh
and I even believe Ukraine would still
continue to uh control crier but it War
hasn't gone uh brilliantly for Vladimir
Putin I think that's fair to say um uh
you know if there had been a peace in
February March
2022 uh do you think Putin would have
had a stronger hand then or a weaker
hand
then Putin did not want this war he went
to Great Lengths before February 24th
2022 uh when the war started to uh
headed off at the past he wanted to come
up with a diplomatic solution and then
shortly after the war broke out in
February uh he was negotiating with the
ukrainians uh to work out a deal uh and
at that point in time he was not talking
about uh incorporating any uh Ukrainian
territory uh safe for Crimea which had
already been an next uh into uh Russia
and all he really cared about it's quite
clear from all the reports of the people
who were involved in the discussions was
NATO expansion into Ukraine he wanted a
neutral Ukraine and if he had gotten a
neutral Ukraine this is right after the
war started I believe there's a good
chance the war could have been shut down
but it was the Americans and the British
who moved in and basically told zalinski
that he had to walk away from the
negotiations because we believed that we
could win the war we meaning Ukraine
plus the West uh and in 2022 it actually
looked like that might be the case but
now it's quite clear that 2023 has been
a disastrous year for the ukrainians and
if anything the Russians will win the
war did you ever think uh then you said
it looked as though Ukraine might be
able to win the war did you ever think
or did you ever say that you thought
that Ukraine might be able to win the
war in
2022 no I didn't think that uh Ukraine
would ever win the war uh I think it was
just a question of when uh Putin decided
to mobilize Russia and get serious about
fighting the war the fact is that he uh
invaded Ukraine with a very small force
uh I argue that he had at the most
190,000 troops uh there are a number of
smart people who pay very careful
attention to what happened uh during The
Invasion who argued that he had at the
most a 100,000 troops but this was a
small military force and of course he
ran into real resistance or the Russians
ran into real resistance inside of
Ukraine uh because the Ukrainian Army
had been trained and armed by the West
this was a quite formidable fighting
force so the ukrainians styed the uh uh
the Russians but it was all a matter of
when the Russians would respond uh to
this stalemate uh that developed in the
summer of 2022 and mobilize uh many more
troops than Ukraine could mobilize and
in fact in late September uh the
Russians mobilized 300,000 troops and
then over the course of 2023 that's this
year uh roughly
420,000 men have joined uh the Russian
army so the Russian army is growing
bigger and bigger and at the same time
the Ukrainian Army is suffering enormous
casualties and it had a much smaller
Manpower pool to draw from to begin with
so in 2022 when the Russians hadn't
fully mobilized it looked like Ukraine
might win but
uh if you factored in mobilization on
the Russian side that was not a
realistic belief are you not um uh and
forgive me if this is impertinent are
you not um slightly underplaying uh the
extent of the Russian invasion at the
beginning of the war I mean they did
Menace Kiev um it did look very much as
though they were intending to take Kev
do you think that was just a
bluff I don't think they could have
taken Kiev if they wanted they just
didn't have enough troops Kiev is a city
that has roughly three million people uh
you know they had tens of thousands of
troops the Russians did uh in the Kiev
area there's no way they were going to
quickly take that it's quite clear that
what the Russians were interested in
doing or to put it more specifically
what Putin was interested in doing was
coercing the ukrainians into coming to
the negotiating table and cutting a deal
on Ukraine joining NATO he was not
interested in conquering Ukraine or
Conquering the rest of Ukraine as I like
to say it's the conventional wisdom in
the west that Putin was bent uh on
conquering all of Ukraine and making
part of a greater Russia uh there is no
way that he could have done this with
190,000 troops if he was interested in
doing that again as I often point out
when the Germans invaded Poland on
September 1st
1939 they went in with you know more
than a million troops uh he would have
needed an army that was Far bigger uh
than the one that went into Ukraine in
February 2022 if he was bent on
Conquering the country and incorporating
it into Russia uh and he was
not well uh let's move on to uh another
controversial subject that you've uh
written about this year um and that is
uh the war in Gaza uh and on your
substack uh you have a very uh
powerfully written piece called death
and destruction in Gaza um which says
you want to be on the right side of
History uh because you believe Israel is
p purposefully massing a huge number of
Ians um and you think uh essentially
it's a an attempted genocide um almost
uh that's quite strong language is it
not I want to be clear I did not say
it's an attempt to genocide in fact I've
said publicly on a number of occasions I
do not believe that the Israelis are
pursuing a genocide here uh a very
prominent Israeli
born scholar of the Holocaust
uh has said that he believes the
Israelis have genocidal intent uh and he
makes it clear he's not arguing that
they're executing a genocide I do
believe that what the Israelis are doing
in terms of murdering huge numbers of
innocent civilians in Palestine or in
Gaza Palestinians in Gaza is a war crime
I think there's no question about that
uh and that's what I was criticizing the
Israelis for but I was not criticizing
them for no you're quite right forgive
me for that I've misquoted you but uh I
mean one thing you do point to a lot in
your piece is the um very violent
statements of senior Israeli commanders
and they are quite shocking some of them
um but I mean I suppose the point is
they have just had a terrorist attack uh
and you know if you look back at 9/11
you know quite senior Americans said
some pretty shocking things in the days
after that uh are we not reading too
much into uh emotional
words I think if you look at the
language the uh Israeli Elite is using
and we're not talking about a few
extremists in the population we're
talking about people in the cabinet
we're talking about active duty generals
retired generals if you look at the
language that they're using uh to
describe the Palestinians uh and to say
or describe what they want to do in Gaza
it's truly shocking uh and the this
language is what leads Omar bartov who
is the Holocaust scholar I was talking
about a minute ago to say that it looks
like there is genocidal intent on the
part of the Israelis and bartov by the
way is not the only person making this
argument other people other Scholars of
of the Holocaust A and of genocide are
making the same point and again I want
to be very clear here the argument is
not that the Israelis are executing a
genocide at this point in time that's
not the argument but there is clear
evidence that they're committing war
crimes by murdering huge numbers of
Palestinian civilians and doing other
things as well like starving the
population inside of Gaza but uh uh you
would not expect this from the Israelis
given the Holocaust given the horrors
that were inflicted on Jews in Europe uh
between
1939 and
1945 you would not expect Israeli
leaders to be talking about the
Palestinians in this way and talking
about doing to Gaza what some of the
leaders are talking about doing um I
suppose an obvious question is what else
do you expect Israel to do about Hamas
because uh they clearly they've had a
huge security failure um and uh Hamas is
an intractable problem for Israel and I
think neighboring Arab states
acknowledge that um that Hamas is a is a
violent cult it is a terrorist
organization it is hellbent on uh
killing as many Israelis and Jews as
possible um how do we expect Israel to
deal with that
problem well there's no question that
Israel has the right uh to retaliate
against Hamas it's completely
understandable that the Israelis are
bent on
eliminating uh Hamas in Gaza one can
understand that but there's a difference
between going after Hamas and punishing
on purpose the civilian population those
two different things if you go after
Hamas if you're the Israelis and you go
after Hamas there is going to be a
significant amount of collateral damage
which is to say a lot of civilians are
going to be killed that's inevitable and
it's in large part because Hamas is
woven in to the civilian population but
the Israelis are not simply going after
Hamas what the Israelis are doing is
they are purposely killing huge numbers
of civilians and the evidence for this
is overwhelming and the evidence comes
from inside Israel itself if you look at
the statements Israeli leaders are
making and if you look at the
assessments of the bombing campaign that
are coming from inside Israel and are
well done assessments it's quite clear
that this is a classic punishment
campaign where the aim is to kill large
numbers of civilians and I believe and
there is a good amount of evidence to
support this that what the Israelis are
interested in doing in the end is
ethnically cleansing Gaza uh I believe
the Israelis would like to ethnically
cleanse Gaza and they would like to
ethnically cleanse the West Bank they'd
like to get rid of the
Palestinians from those two areas very
important to understand Freddy that if
you look at greater Israel which
includes Gaza the West Bank and what is
generally referred to as green line
Israel Israel before
1967 in those three areas that comprise
greater Israel there are approximately
7.3 million Jews and 7.3 million
Palestinians
for Israel this is an intolerable
situation you certainly can't have a
democracy when you have those kind of
numbers because it soon will cease to be
Israel will soon cease to be a Jewish
state so what the Israelis would like to
do or many Israelis would like to do
certainly many Israelis in the present
government is they'd like to ethnically
cleanse Gaza and they'd like to
ethnically cleanse the West Bank and
there's all sorts of evidence to support
this uh so how do you achieve that end
one way to do it is inflict massive
punishment on the civilian population to
directly go after the civilian
population and that's what the Israelis
are doing that's not to deny that
they're not also going after Hamas but
this is not a military operation that is
specifically designed to get Hamas and
nothing
else Joe Biden has been uh quite clear
in his support of Israel and America um
generally tends to be very supportive of
Israel you of course wrote uh a famous
book The the Israel lobby with Steven
Walt um about the pressure that Israel
exerts on Washington to uh pursue
policies that suit Israel um a lot of
people called you anti-semitic for that
and a lot of people will call you
anti-semitic for your arguments now how
do you respond to that do you think
that's
hysterical I think Freddy you can Define
anti-sm iic any way you want and what's
happened here is we have reached a point
where anybody who criticizes Israel in a
serious way is described as an
anti-semite uh I have a number of
friends who are
Jewish uh who are very Jewish and who
are anti-zionists they don't believe in
the Zionist Enterprise they're basically
internationalists at heart according to
most Defenders of Israel they are
anti-semites I think it's ludicrous to
call them anti-semites they're not
anti-semites you can argue that they're
misguided and you can argue that someone
like me is unfair in criticizing Israel
that I'm too harsh in my criticism I
don't think that's true but you can make
that argument but labeling me an
anti-semite or labeling someone who's an
anti-zionist and is as an anti-semite is
I think stretching the definition of
anti-semitism to the point where it
becomes almost meaningless I mean I do
believe there is real anti-Semitism in
the world and I condemn it I think it's
absolutely horrible I think what
happened in Europe for centuries is
disgraceful uh so I'm all in favor of
condemning anti-Semitism as long as it
has some reasonable definition but when
anti-Semitism is stretched to the point
where people like me uh are criticized
uh as uh you know one of the world's
lead for being one of the world's
leading anti-semites I I think you know
we're we're making arguments that just
don't make sense or we're making charges
that just don't make sense do you think
that perhaps there is a bias uh among
the United Nations uh in the European
Union perhaps uh and certainly
International Aid agencies there's a
bias against Israel and there's a
tendency to uh push information to push
statistics uh that are then disputed do
you think there's a a weight of
international opinion that goes against
Israel or would you say actually it's
the other way
around it all depends if you're talking
about the European Union you're talking
about Europe I mean I think the
Europeans basically back Israel uh to
the hilt uh I mean if you look at the
Germans and you look at Britain I mean
there's no evidence that uh the British
government or the British Elites or the
German government or the German Elites
are siding with the Palestinians against
Israel uh there's not a whole heck of a
lot of difference between how most
Europeans uh react to what's going on uh
in Gaza uh there's not much difference
between that and what the Americans are
doing the way I see it uh once you get
outside of Europe uh and the United
States to put it in slightly different
terms once you get outside of the West
there is no question that there is a
huge amount of criticism of Israel uh
for what it's doing to the Palestinians
and you know you talk about Aid agencies
it's not so much the aid agencies it's
the Human Rights group I mean groups you
want to remember that uh Amnesty
International Human Rights Watch and
Bellum which is the leading Human Rights
group inside of Israel itself those
three organizations which have Stellar
reputations from a human right
perspective in my opinion have all
produced lengthy reports that describe
Israel as an aparti State and say that
is a crime against humanity uh and you
can rest assured that when all the dust
settles and these human rights
organizations uh look at what the
Israelis have done uh in Gaza they will
accuse the Israelis of war crimes
justifiably so so you know there is no
question that there is this body of
organizations in various countries
around the world that are highly
critical of Israel and there are people
in the west who are highly critical of
Israel and many of them by the way
Freddy are
Jewish very important to understand that
it's this is not a case where all Jews
are uh supporting what Israel is doing
in Gaza and in fact some of the most
significant resistance inside of the
United States uh to what Israel is doing
is coming from uh Jewish individuals and
Jewish organizations like uh Jewish
voice for peace and not in my name uh so
this is an actually quite complicated
situation uh and it's not like it's all
the world against Israel or everybody
but the United States against Israel it
it just doesn't look like that at all
when you begin to sort of Peel away the
layers of the
onion Jo M uh it's always a pleasure
talking to you um thank you very much
for coming on to spectator TV and thank
you for all your appearances this year
uh I wish you a very happy Christmas and
uh I'm sure everyone will hope for a
more peaceful New
Year now from politics to religion are
we at the beginning of a great Christian
Revival uh we're about to celebrate
Christmas which is of course uh a
Christian celebration but we are
generally I think it's acknowledged
living in in a post-religious
post-christian anyway um Society Ed West
who joins me now um has a very
interesting piece in the magazine uh
about the the headline is the new
theists um and that is a play uh on the
against the new atheists who were the
popular intellectual movement of the
2000s um Ed joins me with Mary
Harrington of unheard um Ed let's start
with you what is the thesis of your uh
piece just sum it up for our viewers
well um my argument is that in the last
20 years there's been a massive decline
in religion I mean religion's been
declining for a while but especially in
the US where religious uh attendance and
belief has hugely dropped since about
2000s um and that sort of came at the
time the new atheist movement was very
fashionable pointing that religion was
responsible for all these social evils
um Christoph hit's you know famous line
religion poisons everything was was the
sort of the best one but um there has
also been kind of range of new studies
and books um social science data
suggesting that religion actually has a
lot of social benefits um in terms of
well-being low
anxiety sort of community sense but also
Christianity in particular had a sort of
hugely beneficial effect in the west and
there are sort of so I saw mention aort
range of books as Jonathan Heights um
The Righteous Mind was probably the the
first one Tom Holland's dominions been
very influential um there's also Joseph
henrik's um the weirdest people in the
world which is particularly about how
Christianity uh shaped modern liberalism
and none of these people are sort
Believers um but I mean the question is
um that I sort of wonder about is
whether people can actually sort of get
the benefits of religion without
believing or whether also they can
actually sort of meme themselves into
believing if people enough people sort
take part in in religious events and
observant then they will start to
believe which I think is is probably
possible explain a little bit what you
mean by meme because it's a it's a term
popularized or coined possibly by
Richard Dawkins isn't it of course who
was the uh the biggest new atheist of
them all yeah it was come from the uh
the the selfish Gene um and uh he's he
you know describes a meme a meme is like
an idea that spreads uh and it it can be
positive or can be negative but it has
sort of benefit to um the person who
spreads it um
and you know mem like religion is a sort
popular meme it's an idea that sort of
spreads almost like a contagion and we
sort of see in politics now I mean lots
of political sort of fashionable ideas
spread um just by sort of repetition or
sort of social networks and obviously
social media makes this much more
extreme and I think that's one reason
why politics has kind of radically
shifted since smartphones come along
because it's just so much more possible
to spread ideas even kind of quite
insane ideas um
over uh over a huge populations but I
always you know so but you can also the
you can use phrases often you know
people meme themselves into some they
sort of adapt adopt the belief um partly
because all their friends do and they
might even do it ironically or they
might even sort of experiment on an idea
and then they eventually sort of talk
themselves into actually adopting a sort
of a Viewpoint or a wellview um or
religion um
and I think you know human beings are
obviously capable of doing this people
mean themselves into all sorts of things
well Mary um prayer is obviously uh
similar to meming in a way isn't it
because it's it's sort of repetition
endless
repetition um and I think it's fair to
say in America there has been this
revival of or there certainly Revival of
interest in traditional
Christianity um is it becoming a fashion
is is it a is it a new trend do you
think that is
emerging there are definitely people who
seem attracted to the Aesthetics more
more than they're particularly
interested in the theology I mean and
and there's there's an unmistakable
Trend at least in in certain minority
quarters for so tweeting from Mass um
which is sort of ambiguous in terms of
how it relates to actual religious
devotion um but I think I I think the
important thing is that at least when at
the Heyday of observant Christianity in
the west it's always was certainly the
case that more people were observant
regular church attenders and so on than
really believed in any sort of deeply
felt sense and you know and there's a
there's there's a sense in which this
idea that the the the truly the truly
passionate Faith should precede the
worship is a very Protestant idea you
know it's a very sort of
post-reformation idea that that says you
know you need to have this personal
relationship with God you know mediated
only by the Bible and that if if that
isn't if if that isn't coming to you
with a burning force of Revelation then
doing it wrong and maybe you should do
something else or like not go to church
um whereas the the perhaps the older
preliterate um relationship to the faith
was that it was just something that you
do um I'm I'm quoting a friend's
grandmother who said that a friend who
said that her grandmother was the the
real traditional catholic so not these
types who tweet from Mass and you know
ostentatiously have encouraged their
girlfriends to wear the veil or whatever
um but the the actual traditional
Catholics um because they only went to
and she said her grandmother was a real
Trad cath because she only went to
master twice a year and she believed in
fairies yeah um Ed you talk about these
new theists uh and they are they do seem
to be um sort of people who were perhaps
uh quite a few of them were uh either
part of the new new atheist movement or
are liberals who are just slightly
alarmed at what the secular world is
doing um to us I wondered just to be a
bit um cynical about it I wonder you
know all those new atheist books sold
very very well um is is it quite as
popular a movement or is it more of a
sort of online intellectual phenomenon
that hasn't really reached the masses um
I don't think there anything like it's
popular I mean the god illusion sold
vast amounts wasn't it I mean new
atheism was was fashionable and it's
succeeded in part because of people
sorts of people are very influenced by
what their peers and the people look up
to think and do and people tend to um
follow those things so I mean uh coming
up the argument is oh actually
Christianity produced liberalism and
Christianity is really good and I know
maybe even we should sort of you know
take part in some of the sort of Rights
of it is is nothing like it's not going
to be anything like as fashionable um or
popular and I think it's probably more
kind of countercultural in the sense
that new atheism like to present itself
as this kind of rebellion against the
mainstream but it was you know it was
very much pushing at an Open Door
religion religious decline was in huge
you it was already happening anyway
amongst the educated um all over the
Western world I mean it was partly
motivated by S fear of Islam but they
didn't it was sort of impolite to say
that and it was definitely like you know
provoked partly by two um 911 um but
actual Christianity was in such decline
it was actually sort of going with the
grain of popular thought um I think
saying that actually Christianity is
good is very much Against the Grain um
in a way I mean I do think particularly
like Tom Holland's book for example uh I
mean Tom you know he says he's not
believer and he s grew up but he grew up
in a kind of Christian environment and
he and he cherishes that and I think
with um a lot of people whose parents
would have been religious and they grew
up vaguely and I kind of occasionally
going to church and the the level of um
secularization amongst their own
children is much more extreme um and
there is definitely a sort of feeling of
loss because once that goes all sorts of
other kind of all sorts of other things
go you know the kind of common Cultural
Literacy I think even the sort you know
the idea of forgiveness which is I think
it is kind of counterintuitive and I
think now we're sort of learning that in
our political our kind of kind of
cultural environment is very not into
forgiveness anymore I mean you know the
council culture thing is very
much you know not Christian in that
sense and and there is a sense of of
loss really no I was want just to add to
Ed's point about the new atheists and
the mass secularization of society I
wonder if one of the things go that's
going on is that we we are now a more
secular culture than not um but the
predictions the new atheist predictions
about what would happen when we all
became a secular culture have manifestly
not been delivered you know they
promised a new golden age of rationality
where everybody would be sensible Like
Richard Dawkins and that's manifestly
not what what secularization has
delivered in you know we now live in a
culture of mass unbelief but the world
is more insane than ever and in a sense
it's more it's more suffused with
religiosity than ever it's just a very
untrammeled and very chaotic and
sometimes very unwisely directed kind of
religiosity and people pour into all
bizarre Cults and um personal fitness
and you know agnostic beliefs about
about their own physical bodies and yeah
all all kinds of all kinds of bizarre
things which have taken on the same sort
of mantle of a mantle of faith that was
once sort of convened and corraled in a
more structured Way by by a mass
religious practice and I think it's it's
po I think maybe not everybody most
people just prefer to mind their own
business but amongst people who think
about things um it's becoming
increasingly obvious that it's not
possible not to be religious you know
that's just that's just how human
societies function and it really is a
question of picking picking which one
and I and I suspect that you know among
again amongst you know some more
reflective often often quite young
people they've come to the conclusion
that perhaps an embodied
Redemptive forgiving kind of a religious
Faith might be superior to some of the
other options out there and and
adjusting their behavior accordingly and
in a sense I think well you know if
you're if you're going to even you why
why why would it not be possible to work
backwards from that to to some to some
of the more sort of protestant coded
mystical forms of belief that seems
eminently possible to me there's no
obvious reason why somebody should come
to come to you arrive at the road the
business start of the road to Damascus
one way or another so well I don't know
but I think I think it's it's just so
obvious that Dawkins was wrong about
what would happen when everyone stopped
believing that people people are taking
practical action well I think uh
chesteron said when people stop
believing in God they'll start believing
in anything do you think Ed we're now
seeing people stop believe people are
stopping to believe in anything and now
perhaps starting to believe in
God um no I mean I do think it's still a
small um kind of online thing but I mean
these things might have the germs of you
know the the seeds of the future uh I
mean I think in in the sort of the
irrationality thing it's you know do
Dawkins who I you know sort of respect
and kind of love in a way I think you
know he's come across he's he's one of
the few members of the new atheist
movement who has really sort of kept his
credibility um and he's been sort of
long ostracized because you know he is
sort of a deeply rational highly
intelligent person and most people
aren't and you know um you know the the
the fact that a lot of the new atheist
movement then pivoted towards kind of
progressivism it became new atheism plus
and it was kind of combating you know
racism and sexism and transfering all
these things and it ended up sort of
adopting very like religious like um
ideas about the world and you know in
particularly on the transgender issue
where there is a kind of incredible
intolerance about anyone who who
disbelieves in this um you know so it
sort of went from sort of transation to
transgenderism within a very short space
of time I mean I was even at the time I
think I was quite cynical about D you
know this kind of rational future but it
happened much quicker than I think
anyone would expected it became um as
Mary says like very religious likee um
but whether you know
whether I mean the problem with sort of
meing yourself back into Christianity is
I you mention it is a very strange
religion in many ways it's very
counterintuitive it's much more sort of
Miracle uh orientated than other
religions um you know especially so
Islam for example so in a way it's kind
of almost like the hardest one to
embrace because it's and its ideas are
so against our kind of instincts in many
ways Mary Ed mentioned the fear of Islam
earlier I mean with with that was
certainly a driver for the new atheism
because it was after 9/11 and um sort of
terrorism becoming a uh a huge problem
uh Islamic terrorism becoming a huge
problem um do you think that perhaps the
Revival of Christianity will also come
even though again it will be impolite to
say so in polite Society uh will also
come from a fear of Islam because people
are looking at um just you know the sh
demographics of it and we can see that
secular culture uh will probably be
overwhelmed by a religious culture uh
and in the west or in Britain it could
well be Islam well hly I think I think
it's unlikely that anybody is going to
be be inspired to A Renewed flourishing
of Christian faith just because they
don't they don't want more Muslims in
their area that just seems implausible
to and and not not to mention not to
mention somewhat incompatible with with
at least the the sort of generally
received understanding of what a
Christian mindset is supposed to look
and feel like um I mean it's it's not
it's not impossible but it seems it
seems to me more um that where where
people feel themselves under threat from
a competing ideology they don't then
adopt a new ideology in order to C
combat it they double down on the one
they currently have so I mean I I I
imagine I a more plausible head-to-head
confrontation I can imagine which is
actually cropping up already in some
parts of America is is a head-on
confrontation between strict Islam and
um gender ideology and and and all the
all that sails within it you know the
The Wider um the the the the the the
greater the greater Church of of of the
rainbow um which which is obviously
obviously at an at a some considerable
angle to observant Islam not least on
claiming that men can be women and so on
which is just obviously obviously
incompatible with with Muslim
traditional sex segregation and you're
already seeing you're already vociferous
arguments um in for example in I think I
believe there was a school somewhere in
in the Midlands where where where there
was a very strong parent push back
against a new curriculum that was that
was brought in on sex education which
included a lot of gender ideology and
there have been there have been um there
have been parents on the streets around
some American schools in heavily Muslim
immigrant communities in America where
they're resisting resisting this this
kind of teaching and I think and and if
you if you see if you see the Church of
rainbow as a church which I mean as as
Ed has described in some respects it
sort of is you I mean the the idea that
that humans can change sex is so
obviously factually false that if you
believe it to be true you can only be
thinking of it in some sort of
allegorical metaphorical spiritual sense
essentially um and and if you if you if
you're looking at them as two two
competing accounts of what a person is
you at a fundamental level then I I see
I see that as a much more plausible
confrontation I mean in my view
political Christianity is probably toast
at Le I mean perhaps not forever but at
least for the for the immediate perhaps
the foreseeable future I don't think
it's I don't think it's toasters of
Faith but I think political Christianity
in the form that's been so dominant in
the West for some centuries is probably
it's it's probably destined for a period
in the Wilderness at this point Ed you
touched on that in in your piece where
you said that well-off people replace
religion with politics and by that I
assume you mean in large part what
Mary's talking about the you know
radical progressivism as a sort of
Article of
Faith uh yes I mean if you look at
surveys um American liberals I I don't
know about in the UK but they they place
I think like one in three Place great
emphasis on their Politics as you know
being very important to them and it's
something like 10% amongst conservatives
so it's much more on the left um you
know people need some sort of moral like
load star that they and where it's not
religion it will be some sort of like
left centered um kind of world view um I
I think on the on the Isam thing it's
kind of it's it's slightly unknown
because what you're looking at is sort
of three-way culture wars between s
progressives and conservatives and Islam
um and and so with when it's kind of
that complex we're not
sure um sort of who's fighting who I
mean even stuff like you know the
British values stuff which was s brought
in in the uh after the sort of terrorism
of 2000s that was sort of basically
people on the left using Islam as a kind
of tool to sort of you know to win
arguments against their conservative
Rivals because it was basically just
making British values were basically
Progressive values um and it make kind
of like an unknown factor when you have
a sort of new group who comes in um uh
who have you know who might be used by
one side to further their own kind of
agenda but they obviously have their own
beliefs and they have their own kind of
idea of what the the world would like to
be which might not particularly fit in
with the lefts I'm not entirely sure
that Islam won't I mean I've become much
more of the view that um Islam will also
basically come
be undermined heavily by progressivism
by you know secularism I mean amongst
younger uh Muslims um in Britain and and
the West generally I think a lot of them
are um very much adopting the kind of
same political
ideas as other people um I mean all this
depends on also Geo like geopolitical
factors might changes I mean obviously
if they War when when people can adopt
you know people's religious identity can
become much more important to them in
you know in the face of conflict well we
and we've seen that with Gaza haven't we
yeah I mean the last yeah the last few
weeks obviously it becomes hugely
important to people who might not have
been thinking about it that much I mean
there was actually I mean the question
about people's religious Faith there was
I remember there was Data a while back
showing that in England where there was
a large Muslim population a large number
of local s of white British people did
identify as Christian even if they
didn't actually go to church so it
obviously became uh more of an important
identity to to them um not enough to
actually you know get back in the swing
of things but you know religion has
always been you know very linked to sort
of ethnic identity in many many
different places you around the world so
it's not impossible that it could become
a kind of locus for kind of identity
conflict in the future the the Church of
rainbow expressivism is now is
increasingly strongly us Imperial coded
um I mean the we you only have to think
about the the the US Embassy flying the
pride flag at the Vatican or you know
the the the immediate jump from with
Afghan withdrawal to you know what
what's what's going to happen to the
LGBT minorities there um and the and the
and the sense in you know and this the
the the the sheer volume of video
content that came out of Ukraine in the
first in the first few weeks of that
conflict which focused on Ukraine's LGBT
friendliness um there's a there's a
sense in which if you're an American
Ally you're you're for this stuff and if
you're if you aren't for this stuff then
you're not an American Ally and you'll
be regime changed um so I think you know
to to the to the extent that people want
to present themselves as as America
friendly um this it it's being it's
being adopted as as something you know
in a sort of Constantine like way yes I
if you've ever been to any uh cities in
America the number of churches which
actually are beded in Rainbow Flags is
quite striking yeah it's it's
particularly the Unitarian universalists
yes yeah uh it's an absolutely
fascinating subject but we better wrap
it up there um I uh I um thoroughly
recommend you all read Ed's piece which
is in the spectators Christmas edition
I'll wave it around uh and thank you
very very both very very much for coming
on to spectator TV and I wish you both a
very spiritual and highly religious
Christmas that's it for uh the week in
60 minutes this uh Year Edition of the
week in 60 minutes uh I hope you've
enjoyed it all um we've certainly
enjoyed doing it for you I would like to
urge you before we go to subscribe to
The Spectator magazine uh look at this
beautiful Christmas edition uh you'll
get one of those next year or this one
if you act quickly enough um and I
should also urge you to subscribe to our
YouTube channel if you do not already
you can do that by hitting the Subscribe
button and finally I would like to wish
all of you a very very happy
[Music]
Christmas